okay sure rush is my wife Robin this is
I think what your name sorry ah Gordon
Moseley right Gordo Hey
Wow buddy I did not recognize you garden
Mosley oh my gosh finally Gordo and I
went to school together like I don't
know what this is been so who's lucky
charm you guys sure you're in the best
shape to be done this oh yeah
we have just one hand on the steering
wheel huh
when you hear something that sounds like
a gunshot drive can you open the door
I'll buy the plane Benji can you open
the door
maybe BEC these bangers make sure
they're clean all right I'm sorry these
are not bangers okay these um these are
artists
excuse me artists yeah seriously
yeah what kind of artists rappers and
they're working with me in the studio
right now well see rappin is not an art
and I'm sorry who are you
I'm the manager well you wasting your
time mr. manager you got to be kidding
me you're wasting your time really these
clients of yours these rappers yeah they
look like Gangnam
come down here and arrest people